hey this is presh talwalkar
a singapore math question on students
birthday months has everyone stumped
again
this is according to mothership
what is the question
there are 37 students in a class
how many students at the least are born
in the same month
you did hear that correctly
and i know what you're thinking
this problem is too easy
obviously the answer is zero is the
least number
you can have all 37 students with
birthdays in one month
so the other months would all have zero
student birthdays
this means the least number is zero
now i'm going to give some credit to
this singapore math question the problem
likely intended something else so let's
speculate on what the problem was really
about and then solve those problems
so one speculation
is the following
how many students do you need in a group
to be guaranteed at least two students
have birthdays in the same month
another possibility
is that there are 37 students in a class
the students compare birthdays and find
some month contains more birthdays than
any other month
that month has x birthdays
what is the least possible value for x
can you figure out these problems
give them a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the answer
so for the first possibility how many
students do you need in a group to be
guaranteed at least two students have
birthdays in the same month
the answer is 13 students
you could have 12 students who had
birthdays in 12 different months
but then the 13 student must have a
birthday in the same month as someone
else
this is an example of a powerful
counting principle known as the
pigeonhole principle
if you have n pigeon holes to contain
more than n pigeons
that at least one pigeonhole has to
contain more than one pigeon
there's an alternate form of this
principle which loosely states that the
maximum value has to be at least the
average value
and this version is useful in many
problems
and we'll use it to solve the second
possibility for what this problem was
intending
so
this possibility is that there are 37
students in the class and the students
compare birthdays and find some month
contains more birthdays than any other
month
that month has x birthdays what is the
least possible value for x
so let's use the principle that the
maximum value is at least the average
value
we'll compute the average number of
birthdays per month
there are 37 birthdays to be divided by
12 months
this makes for 3
and 1 12 birthdays per month
so the maximum value the month with the
most birthdays has to be at least as
large
this means the maximum value is at least
four birthdays
and that's the least possible value for
x
there's another way that you could see
this
think about distributing the students
into the months
you can put 36 students as three per
month
but then the 37 student would be forced
to be in some month which is the same as
these other students
so that month would have at least four
birthdays
so there's two different ways of seeing
this answer but the correct answer to
this is that x is four
did you figure these problems out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description
and you can support me on patreon
you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com if you have a
puzzle suggestion or math topic and you
can catch me on social media either at
mind your decisions or at preshtalwalkar